also new on 8 news now at six disputes
continue for the Henderson Police
Department as we hear from the police
chief for the first time since two
unions voted no confidence in him so so
is addressing several claims now made
against him he sat down with Victoria
Saha who joins us now live in studio
with more on what he had to say Victoria
yeah Brian and Denise there's a lot of
back and forth here with both unions and
the Henderson Police Chiefs say as they
don't appear on the same page the union
saying their vote was a long time coming
and the chief Frederick Andres says it
comes as a shock
Henderson a city that is touted for
being one of the safest in the country
but there's turmoil within a police
department that's supposed to be keeping
the city safe it doesn't occur simply
because who is the chief of police we've
gone through five or six during my
career Lieutenant Chris aguar works with
the department and is part of the
Henderson Police supervisors Association
one of the two unions of voting no
confidence in Chief Frederick Andres my
confidence remains High because of the
great work we're doing in a letter sent
the unions pointed out several issues
such as a new use of force policy
implemented with no training or
communication from the chief we want to
keep our officers safe and have a policy
that makes it clear and that there's no
confusion but Chief Andra says otherwise
a lot of confusion is being put in place
intentionally and I want to make sure
that's very clear we would not put a
policy out that we didn't train on the
letter also calling Chief Andres an
outsider who is trying to fix what's not
broken when talk about the new use of
force policy what they want is policies
from the past that doesn't hold them
accountable the two unions pointing out
over 95 percent of their members put in
their no-confidence vote do you believe
you could successfully leave this
department with such a high percentage
of your officers expressing such a lack
of confidence in your leadership I think
it's important to note that you know
when you think about that I've been here
for four and a half years right right at
four years and nine months I have
successfully LED this department and the
officers Union saying they just want to
be heard it's not that we have to be
right on everything we just want to see
it at the table and and honest
communication we actually want to have
input not just meeting with us to check
a box to say that you met with us
when talking about this new use of
fore's policy Chief Andres says training
should start for officers in January
it's meant to have more critical
thinking from officers and try to
de-escalate a situation first whenever
they can Denise